[Musique]
et on retrouve mélanie qui comme chaque
semaine nous fait part de ses
découvertes pour les plus jeunes
et aujourd'hui vous êtes venu nous
présenter un livre sur les petites bêtes
celle qui vengera des grosses peut-être
dans des petites bêtes que nous parfois
adultes on trouve repoussante mais que
les enfants aimeraient bien touché alors
le titre du livre les petites bêtes qui
font peur mais pas trop c'est françois
lasserre qui l'a écrit françois et
enseignants et entomologiste
c'est-à-dire un scientifique qui étudie
les insectes
il est aussi vice-président de l'opi
l'office pour la protection des insectes
et de leur environnement qui est basé à
guyancourt
quand on s'intéresse à la nature et en
particulier aux insectes et aux
araignées on se rend compte que tout le
monde est un peu démunis on attend on
apprend pas grand chose donc c'est un
bouquin qui s'adresse un peu aux parents
beaucoup aux enfants pour toute la
famille un livre pour tout le monde
alors qu'est ce qu'on y trouve dans
mélanie on y trouve 50 antisèches les
questions sur toutes les questions qu'on
peut se poser on va en voir à l'écran la
première les chauves-souris sustt elle
le sent alors on apprend que oui mais il
ya mais les seules chauves souris qui le
font se trouve en fait en amérique
tropicale donc bien loin de nous et en
plus à une novice guerre à les humains
parce qu'elles préfèrent les autres
manifs r une autre réponse à une
question si on touche un crapaud attrape
temps des boutons alors moi c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit mais de peur j'ai jamais
essayé jamais touché alors là aussi pas
d'inquiétude parce que chez les humains
en fait on a la peau assez étanche pour
ne rien attrapé et si vous en toucher 1
il suffit de vous laver les mains et de
ne pas vous toucher les yeux parce que
là vous pourriez vous irriter il faut
aussi savoir et c'est bien ce que vous
faites camille il ne faut pas les
toucher parce qu'en fait ce sont des
animaux fragiles
elle est dernière question camille est
ce que vous avez peur des araignées et
surtout de cette fameuse question qu'on
s'est tous posé un jour peut-on avaler
une araignée en dormant je préfère même
pas y penser enfin parce que je dors pas
toutes les nuits c'est certain alors une
fois de plus je vous rassure et enfin
ces mêmes françois qui va vous rassurer
écoutez le ce serait vraiment une
araignée suicidaire quoi c'est un gain
conduit chaud humide il la ventilation
ça sent l'homme de partout
l'araignée n'a rien à faire dans une
gauche les araignées elles prennent tous
nos fantasmes toutes nos idées reçues et
y compris les légendes urbaines tandis
que les araignées pendent sous la peau
qui a des petits bébés araignées qui
sortent de la peau quand on gratte le
bouton ce qui est archifaux on dit qu'on
peut en manger la nuit quand on dort ce
qui est archifaux aussi vous voilà donc
rassurés camille ces petites bêtes sont
inoffensives et pour toutes les autres
questions que vous vous posez
le livre est devra faire sans voler vos
peurs et comme dirait un trio a bien
connu les insectes sont nos amis il faut
les aimer rossi merci beaucoup mais la
nuit pour cette chronique vous a
présenté cet ouvrage en tout cas le cpcq
loisirs est maintenant terminée c'est la
fin comment mêler les pinceaux mais
c'est pas grave je me retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et je vous souhaite un très bon week-end
[Musique]